you hadn't actually planned on being
here you're a baby brother kevin hart
was that's what you call him your baby
brother yeah he was supposed to be here
but he was in a car beeps go so
everything's good with him now though
right everything is good I spoke with
Kevin I actually heard him as my son
I've connected with him today and you
know what these things happen in life
and thankfully he was strapped in nicely
to his car seat so I think that spoke to
the pediatrician and he he's doing very
well he's bummed he couldn't be here as
you know but look I love the guy he's
one of my best friends and and honestly
I mean thank God it could have been
could have been a lot worse so he's a
lucky man and I'm so happy he's you know
yeah and he's and he knows it too and I
wish him the best and speedy recovery
and I'm gonna see him soon and you two
have the best chemistry I mean I love
every film you've done together like I
love y'all and Jumanji I'm gonna be real
with you okay Dwayne I saw it when I saw
the preview that they were doing another
Jumanji I was like that's not a good
idea cuz like the original was so good
yeah but yours was amazing like so much
my family my kids we all they loved the
part where the hippo eats Jack Black
every time but yeah it's weird I don't
want kids like that that's weird all
kids love that by the way yes I love
that part
a little Jeffrey Dahmer with it yeah I
go in it but you literally yell are
hilarious so we got some
behind-the-scenes footage for the sequel
on your birthday let's see it thank you
to this hard-working crew I love you
guys into my favorite actors Karen
Jackie
it's a pleasure to spend my birthday we
should mention that the new Jumanji
movie
Jumanji the next level comes out
December 13th and I'm till they come to
the premiere right you are I never asked
anything but I really want to come yeah
or come as my guest not Kevin's okay I
[Laughter]
love him I'm literally gonna nerd out
just as much but y'all do really seem to
connect and it's amazing and but also we
recently my family we took our 12 year
old on a date night my husband died and
we saw hubsan shot that was with Hobbs
and sha thank you guys so much you know
you make these movies and you put your
best foot forward and you hope that
people respond to them and with Hobbs
and sha we wound up being just this past
weekend we went to being the number one
movie in the world again for four
weekends in a row and we broke a record
it's insane so the previous record was
held by Avengers and Captain Marvel and
we beat the superhero so it's crazy so
yeah so thank you guys so much for the
support
[Applause]
I love superhero films and I love you so
I feel like everyone making super here
maybe somebody make him a super glam I
want you to do it but anyway I'm sorry I
take away from any me but it was the
best yes it was we had the best wedding
we got married in kawaii on a cliff
quite beautiful yes my lovely bride
Lauren
we met probably about six weeks ago and
you know just over ten years but so it
was a beautiful beautiful wedding and I
got to tell you you know with something
like this as you know as you guys can
imagine it's hard to keep something like
that under wraps but it was so private
and there was maybe ten people with our
babies and it was just the best wedding
and obviously I we totally ended up
eloping we had this big plan and then we
just took our kids and then got married
this person we didn't know but it was
the most amazing thing under like a
little fortune room on a river it was so
beautiful yes it's cool that you made it
intimate because your life is always in
the public eye yeah it's like it's noisy
as you know so with all that we just
figured we wanted to pivot and go the
other way and not do anything that was
[Applause]
is that you always look like the person
that's in the frame in the store you're
walking through HomeGoods and you're
like what family looks like that your
family looks like that well I mean look
that by the way is after 28 takes of me
scrolling through my phone no no no no
perfect I know but we usually people
don't have even the one Dewayne but it's
that time I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this